I'd love to hear your story in terms of
was there a certain film that made you
want to be a writer your choice in your
college major yeah when I was in high
school the film the world according to
GARP had a big impact on me it was about
a writer whose mother was a nonfiction
writer and my mother was also a kind of
aspiring nonfiction writer very
different from the character but still
that that movie was the first movie that
I was like there's something that I
related to in that movie that was
different from any other movie I'd ever
seen it made me think about you know
somebody wrote that you know which was a
phrase the writers guild used in an ad
campaign once to get respect for writers
somebody wrote that they had all these
lines of dialogue on Billboard's you
know don't forget a writer wrote that an
actor didn't just come up with that set
but anyway the world according to GARP
had an impact and I think when I went to
college I I knew I wanted to pursue
something creative that involved writing
whether it was fiction or screenwriting
or maybe even music and so after a year
or two I settled in on on becoming a
film major and and maybe trying to
become like a writer director because a
lot of my favorite movies at that time
were writer director movies like you
know Woody Allen movies of that era like
late 70s early 80s and so I did I
pursued being a film major in my
undergraduate in Ohio which is my home
state and got a four-year degree BFA and
motion picture production which of
course guarantees you a job in the
industry immediately when you show up
with that and I just thought I was gonna
move to Los Angeles and become an
assistant because I kind of knew you
know that whole starting the William
Morris mailroom kind of thing that I
knew that that was a thing you could do
there were people that had moved out to
LA from Dayton Ohio where I was from
before me who'd gone to my film school
before me who had these kind of jobs
working as assistants at the studios and
stuff so I decided that's gonna be my
path I'm gonna get it my day job will be
one of those kind of jobs where I'll be
like a secretary and I'll just be
writing on the side and so that's what I
pursued and
was lucky enough to get into the Fox
Studios kind of in-house temp pool where
somebody in the human resources
department had all these temps that
every day they would assign to these
different jobs throughout the studio
where they needed somebody to fill in
for a day or a week or a month or
whatever because some assistant was on
maternity leave or out sick or had just
left and they hadn't replaced them yet
so I got my taste of all these different
kinds of jobs throughout 20th Century
Fox and the Fox Network you know
everything from like legal department to
accounting and finance like very
corporate departments but also some of
the eventually the more creative side
where you're working on a TV show or
working for a production company which
is of course what you really want if
you're an aspiring writer and so I did
that for a number of years and
eventually got assigned to Tom Hanks his
production company just as a temp which
turned into a full-time assistant job
working there where it was basically him
and his his main assistant who went with
him on location and had been with him
for years and me I was like the guy in
the office like answering the phone and
opening the mail he was off shooting
Forrest Gump for like five months at one
point you know on the East Coast and I
was the only one there in the office
kind of holding down the fort so to
speak at his little production company
that was based at Fox at that time so
while I was doing that I was writing
scripts on the side and I had worked as
a writer's assistant on the show picket
fences right before I worked for Tom
Hanks and got to know other people at my
level other assistants which is a really
helpful thing to do you know they say do
you have to move to Los Angeles to be a
screenwriter you don't have to it helps
and but one of the main reasons it can
help is if you're the kind of person
that gets a job in the business like
that where you're around people doing
what you want to be doing and you meet
people at your level who are also trying
to do the kinds of things you want to do
and you can sort of help each other and
that certainly worked out for me because
I switched from writing features on spec
to I took a class at UCLA extensions
writers program where I have taught now
in recent years myself on sitcom writing
I started writing a spec script for the
show Fraser in that class and then when
it was done I showed it to this friend
I'd work with on picket fences who was a
fellow
assistant but also an aspiring writer
who had just gotten an agent and she
liked the Fraser and was willing to show
it to her agent and the agent like the
Fraser enough to want to sign me so I
got this agent while I was still working
as an assistant for Tom Hanks and this
agent functioned kind of like managers
do now managers weren't such a thing
back then where she was giving me notes
you know she signed me off it but then
she immediately wanted me to rewrite it
with all these notes she gave me before
she would send it to anyone and so then
she had me after that was done she had
me start my next one which was a mad
about you and after that of friends so I
was like pumping out these sitcom spec
scripts cuz in those days when you
wanted to work on staff on a show in the
90s they more valued specs of existing
shows whereas nowadays it's its original
pilots that writers tend to use for
writing samples to get into TV writing
you know a staff job like that which is
normally how you get in is you know you
get hired as like a staff writer on a
show if you're one of the lucky few
fortunate few so that's the direction I
was headed but I still had the the Tom
Hanks really great sort of assistant day
job but I was really starting to think
eventually I'm gonna be a professional
writer now I mean I have an agent she's
sending my stuff out I got some meetings
here and there but then things took a
funny turn an amazing turn which is that
one day Tom Hanks read one or two of
those scripts because his assistant who
I worked kind of under I think
recommended oh you should have Tom read
your you know it'd be fun whatever I
don't know I was never gonna ask him to
read my stuff or help me in any way cuz
I knew this is my job this is he's not
there to help me do that
and he apparently liked the one or two
scripts he read and decided that I had
talent and he told me my talents were
being wasted and he offered me this like
amazing life-changing promotion the week
of my 30th birthday I had a wife and a
kid and she was a teacher and I was
making seven hundred hours a week I
think or something like that so it was a
really good time to get a promotion
where I was gonna help him basically
help him develop this miniseries he had
sold to HBO as an executive producer
which was from the earth to the moon
which was about the Apollo space program
he had done the movie Apollo 13 and was
a life long
ace junkie and at this point was the
biggest star in Hollywood he had gotten
to that point by then and so he was able
to sell this idea for a miniseries of
very expensive 12 hour miniseries where
we would dramatize and recreate the
entire Apollo program right all these
other missions you know so I then helped
him kind of figure out the sort of
outline for that and like find writers
to write the episodes you know
professional screenwriters that were
already established unlike me but
eventually I got to write one of the
scripts and then eventually that script
became a decent script because it took a
long time and then I got asked to help
rewrite some of the other scripts so by
the end of that production from the
earth´s of the moon I had kind of been
an apprentice producer on the whole
thing so I got a co-producer credit on
the whole thing and I had writing credit
or pieces of writing credit on several
episodes and I just like learned all
this stuff from just being on it from
beginning to end and being able to be
kind of in the middle of it because I
worked for Tom and he was the executive
producer so I was on the set in the
editing room and did everything or
watched everything and so when it won
the Emmy for Best miniseries and all the
other big awards I got to share in those
awards because I was one of the
producers so that was really how I got
my start I was very fortunate and that
the first thing I wrote professionally
not only got produced which you know
most things the writers get paid to
write still don't get produced right you
can make a whole career of writing
things that don't get produced not only
to get produced but I was a producer on
it and one these major awards for being
that so it was kind of a fairy tale
beginning of a career that hat that I
owe to Tom Hanks and to you know this is
a cutting which you wouldn't think
translates into historical drama about
the space program but I somehow managed
to figure out how to how to write for
that series even though it wasn't the
kind of stuff I was doing on my own
you